je suis toujours
ce matin
à
ça nous chante si tu arrives tu es
frérot s'éclater au sol t'amuser nous de
la bonne musique la saisie
roddick
tarifs
on a poussé
sellar stade du moment c'est julia beats
qui est avec nous depuis août 18 ans qui
t'arrive tu commences à me battre avec
moi quand romandie julien beyrouth
beyrouth
c'est ça c'est à quel âge
bah j'ai 12 ans - 12 ans aux alentours
et c'est un truc dommage mais c'est un
truc de ouf ce qui t'arrive bah ouais
poteau frais ou en toi tu es mon frérot
tu sais pas comment je te kiffe
ben moi aussi je tenais même en
guadeloupe avec tes yeux parce que c'est
le buzz du moment c'est un truc de ouf
d mais c'est toujours t'es trop fort
frère bah ouais bah c'est normal quoi on
envoie de la sauce pendant longtemps les
experts du rap s'appelait olivier cachin
ou fred musa
mais ça c'était avant j'appréciais à
moitié franchement ce qui vient de se
passer leur la relève s'appelle
maintenant julien bits
il s'agit d'un youtuber qui depuis
quelques jours fait le buzz sur internet
un garçon âgé de seulement 12 ans mais à
la répartie plus que percutante
t'adapter j'ai encore ma ti peau de bébé
j'ai pas de bouton
hier son physique de garçon tranquille
se cache un peu de slayer de talent un
youtube heures qui juge les rappeurs
sans leur faire de cadeaux pius ne
revient pas cette musique et mag avait
il saisir aussi revoir ce que je ressens
c'est comme un ouragan moi ce que je
ressens ça pue la merde en quelques
jours celui qui était encore un inconnu
cumule déjà des centaines de mines et de
vue maintenant que je pèse dans le bain
il faut laisser la star tranquille
julien beats nous fait l'honneur d'être
dans pp mpc c'est un honneur de tabac -6
un honneur de voir tu les connais des
bleus n'ont pas je connais ni âmes est
non mais la dame là non balade - je
connais et lui je le connais mais désolé
mais tranquille je connais pas ton
prénom l'école te connais bien tassée
sur int est posée et aux comores à
seulement 12 ans tu kartonn tu fais des
millions de vues avec tes vidéos dans
lesquelles tu critiques des albums de
rap et j'ai franchement même moi qui
suis dans la vanne tout ça je suis
franchement je suis éclatée par rapport
à toi tu vas trop vite je vais trop vite
j'ai pas le tango c'est vraiment moi je
vais ma vidéo je l'arrêté hop on met sur
youtube et ça fait des centaines de
millions de vues c'est vraiment sens
alors comment comment ça tu es venu
chercher même pas en fait j'aime bien le
rap et je me suis dit bah on va réagir
et aller hop et quelques semaines plus
tard on bat le buzz le buzz vient à moi
on peut être marquer sont là tu ne t'en
penses vas-y
seul s'est éclatée par exemple mais ça
c'est moyen
parce que la musique au début j'étais
très bien je l'aimé bien mais au bout
d'un moment c'est fatigant poteau
tmusique mais moi du de la bonne comme
on a eu sa voix ça par exemple mais on
comprend pas ce qu'ils nient on est
fatigués en une minute celui-là
arrêtez-moi d'autres attaques à moi toi
et je connais pas
alors suivez ses moyens ça revient trop
à la radio c'est du classique doudou
doudou haribo tient tant que tu y es tu
accroches pas non je n'accroche pas
tellement alors aujourd'hui j'étends
mais tout ça c'est le frérot ça c'est 11
ha ouais ouais bah moi aussi ouais je
connais booba battu l'aiment bien et
booba c'est le duc c'est le trône
sevani des efforts il est fort pas une
réforme c'est un ami gesson son dernier
sous les eaux
mon amour c'est tros alerte ses grosses
audiences c'est hanouna d'actifs et
quand il a dit bonjour
ouais bah bondage l'émission web obama
de valider ouais dis-moi comment ça se
passe à l'école moi je me fais
reconnaître mais après c'est normal mais
on est là on fait notre petite vie
tranquille quoi se balade et tapas des
noms ça va ça se passe bien dès qu il
n'ya pas qu'il y ait maintenant que
c'est une star genre il a changé ou pas
du tout non non faut rester comme on est
quoi apache lost est resté normal quoi
et tes parents disent quoi bah ils sont
contents pour moi quoi ils regardent des
vidéos
bah ouais ils ont vu après mon buzz
après boss si l'on peut dire à quoi ils
savaient pas trop avant tenant il savait
pas trop et on dit quoi
bah ils étaient contents ils étaient pas
fier de moi et moi la sa des frères et
soeurs bah ouais ils sont là dans le
public c'est ce que j'ai vu là voilà way
avait en fait les rentrées délais c'est
ado frères way fait les rentrées fait
leur entrée alors julien semoun
enjoignait c'est le plus gros buzz du
moment il fait des millions de vues sur
youtube ce commentaire comment ça va
vous étiez deux frères alors comment ça
va abba super
comment vous appelez alexandre alexandre
est alors alors attendez alors est
généralement ici ça fonctionne pas vous
avez quel âge 28 mois attend est votre
votre petit frère ccc ya pas de batterie
c'est quand même énorme
les vagues sont les routes
oui ça marche ou pas c'est bon
merci ni quel beau petit frère c'est ces
domaines ont franchement on est tous
ceux c'est incroyable ce qui nous tombe
dessus et bah bravo à lui 1
parce que vous essayez le dodo l'entouré
ouais ouais ouais mais par contre on le
laisse faire ce qu'il veut dans ce qu'il
fait dans ces vidéos il est dans
incroyables mais incroyable et un koala
bugat et et toc est temps pour toi quel
usage est conseillé de le protéger il
faut le protéger parce que il à guilad
12 ans en fait mais heureusement qu'il a
12 ans parce que c'est son âge aussi
qu'il protège c'est ça quelque sorte
mais en tout cas on remercie quand même
l'ensemble des gens qui n'ont qui l'ont
qu'il en ait jusqu'ici parce que on a
quand même remarqué une certaine
bienveillance et ça c'est génial c'est
génial parce que il le mérite il mérite
là bien des rôles clés comment tu vois
pas qui fait tu peux même fracassé tout
le monde on va remettre qui fait quand
même parce que tu es drôle
bah oui je suis normal j'ai une petite
surprise pour toi parce que tu me la
surprise est un pote regarde bah ouais
mais regarde
à l'époque je voulais faire une grosse
grosse grosse dédicace un langage bien
beats un gros big up a toi mon gars
quand je vais me mettre des voitures
vraiment ça me va et elle grosse force
ça lui sert il salue toute l'équipe de
touche pas à mon poste
amen ou vite julien on a des choses à
lui dire sur mes côtés ramenez-nous le
petit l'habite habite à la bientôt
liquide
c'est près de megan quaeroq est au top
et tu vas faire plein d'autres
les frérots apparemment voilà et ferait
que j'embrasse fort et skyrock c'est ma
radio préférée vous le savez donc je les
embrasse très très très très très très
fort skyrock et m'ont dit foule d'amour
et bien sûr toute la direction de
skyrock que j'aime et julien julien
essai c'est pas un phénomène très bon il
est exceptionnel voilà j'espère que vous
allez kiffer c'est vraiment le buzz du
moment
m